en cinquième position donc ceux qui font
partie des meilleures années de la
classe il arrive il vient d'arriver il
est déjà 5e c'est Jean-Marie Bigard
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Marie 7,5 7,5 % des votes il est 5e
je fais partie des bons élèves en 4e
position c'est une surprise c'est une
surprise ni parce qu'elle vient pas très
souvent elle est quatrième avec un score
de 11.6 elle n'est pas là aujourd'hui
c'est Béatrice Rosen
Béatrice 11,6%
Béatrice qui est très aimé c'est très
émue
tout est tout est bon
[Musique]
tu comprends vraiment que c'est le
public
[Rires]
on entre dans le trio de tête le
chroniqueur qui prend la troisième place
c'est un chroniqueur
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien c'est super
saison il prend la deuxième place avec
15,1%
le chroniqueur que le public a décidé de
mettre en deuxième position c'est
Matthieu Delormeau
[Applaudissements]
portable
[Rires]
prépare-toi
alors et le chroniqueur ou la chronique
que le public a estimé faire la
meilleure rentrée chroniqueuse avec un
score de 30,2 %. c'est
mon mon Gilles
c'est une chroniqueuse
[Applaudissements]
et apparemment apparemment donc quand un
chroniqueur insulte Mathieu Delormeau il
monte dans les sondages et grave
c'est proportionnel voilà ce qu'il
disait la dernière fois alors là
merci beaucoup je suis comme un dingue
ma gueule et
[Applaudissements]
et je dédie cette première place à
Mathieu elle est pour toi bébé
[Applaudissements]